[Music]
all right y'all it is an
absolute trip to be here at our studio
conference
talking to all of you about the r for
data science online learning community
sharing a little bit about my personal
story and then talking
about diversity equity and inclusion in
data science
and that's a lot to cover in the next 15
20 minutes but we can do it
i mean the reason this is so kind of
wild to be here is that this is not
something that kids like me
traditionally grow up and do
i grew up to a poor working class family
outside of buffalo new york
and i am the first and only person in my
family to both go to
and graduate from college and i really
liked college so much that i ended up
going to graduate school twice
um and i did college at the
uh yeah like use people feel me i can
tell already like i did
college at the education at any cost
model
um to give you some perspective i
graduated from high school in 1999 but i
took eight years to finish my undergrad
which means i graduated into the
recession of 2008
so there were lots of jobs for people
with degrees
so i have a ton of student loans i went
through a variety of careers i did
academia for a little while
and i ultimately ended up teaching high
school science and i loved it
but i'm not sure if you know this
teaching doesn't pay the bills
it is an amazing career i recommend it
for everybody but if you are carrying
six figures worth of student loan debt
teaching is probably not going to help
you make ends meet
so i was in this position in about 2014
where i was evaluating my life
and i knew a couple of things one i
really liked video games
and to be very specific i really liked
world of warcraft
and to be even more specific in the
spirit of vulnerability
i could play world of warcraft for like
12 to 15 hours a day
so there are some things going on in my
life but i really liked video games
i really liked video games and data
science was becoming a thing
and it didn't seem like a fad but data
science was like okay i have some
background
that could maybe put me in a position
where i could do data science and guess
what i don't think i need to go back to
school to become a data scientist
so i think that maybe i could do this
thing i could be a data scientist
and i could change my financial future
so through a variety of kind of weird
coincidences and situations
i found myself interviewing for this
nebulously defined data-ish position
with an esports startup based out of
dallas texas
called pvp live to this day
i don't know where i got the courage to
tell them i was a data scientist
i don't i was registered in the johns
hopkins data science specialization from
coursera but i took none of the classes
like most of you here i'm sure and i had
taken
a graduate level statistics course for
one semester
and i knew a little bit about this
language called
r but the fact remained that i knew more
about data science than anybody at the
company so nobody knew
that i was maybe i wasn't a data
scientist so i said i'm a data scientist
and they hired me um so i worked
remotely for a while and then they told
me to move to dallas or find a new job
so i moved to dallas
um and my first day on the job they were
like congratulations you're a manager
and i was like cool like maybe i don't
even need to learn data science like i
you know like i'll just manage data
scientists so that was really cool
and then six months on the job i'm
spending more and more of my time
managing data scientists and in helping
them learn data science and i'm learning
a little bit as i go but really i'm
learning a lot about
managing and being at a startup i mean
you know this is six months in the job
and it's new and it's exciting and this
is kind of amazing i told this company i
was a data scientist and they hired me
as a data scientist and then they
promoted me as a manager of data
scientists
i was like this is so easy like you just
tell people you're a data scientist and
they hire you
so 12 months into the job without
warning and without notice they let us
go without pay
and that is something of a misnomer
because they told me i could have equity
but if your company makes zero revenue
your equity is still zero like i knew
enough math to know that this was not
going to work out in my favor
so i'm in dallas i've renewed my lease
i've gambled everything on data science
and this esports startup
and i've kind of lost so what do i do do
i go back to teaching i know teaching's
not going to pay the bills but i know i
love it but then i've got to get
certified in texas and that's a process
or do i try to find something data
related or data adjacent and i decided
to see what i could do with data and
maybe let go of the data scientist title
does it matter if i'm called a data
scientist or does it matter if i'm
working with data
and i was like well i guess it matters
that i'm working with data but this time
i'm going to work for a company that i
believe in i did believe in the esports
startup for a while
but i was like i need someone with a
little more a little more clout
so i ended up working for the girl
scouts of northeast texas
and ultimately a teaching trust which is
where i am now and i do
strongly recommend working for
non-profits to kind of start getting
your feet wet with data related careers
i've had all sorts of titles i've been
an analyst i've been in research and
evaluation i've been in outcomes and as
long as you let go of that data
scientist title i think that you can get
started with data science
just about anywhere so i was in this
position where i'm i'm working
in non-profits and i'm i'm doing
analytical work but i'm moving into
management it turns out once you're a
manager like it's hard to not be a
manager ever again because people are
like oh no
we just want you to manage um so
i'm here and i'm leveling up on the side
and i'm like i want to get better at r i
kind of know this language i think it's
really useful i think it can make a lot
of what i do at work better
so as an educator i was like i'm going
to
teach myself r i'm going to get better
at this but i'm going to be transparent
about my process and i'm going to share
that process with other people
so i took to social media and twitter
and i was tweeting about things and i
was writing blog posts and my first blog
posts were helping people navigate that
gap between using your computer for
netflix
and using your computer to do data
science
and forget the gap between excel and r
the gap between using your computer for
netflix and the gap between navigating
rstudio
is very very real and people need those
resources
so as i was doing this two things happen
someone on twitter was like there's this
really good book called r for data
science and it's free and i was like oh
cool
like i will read the book um but then
hadley retweeted me
and this is the most popular i've ever
been on twitter it's probably the most
popular i will ever be on twitter and
that's okay
but i was benefiting from something that
for some people we informally refer to
as the hadley bump right
for 15 minutes this is my 15 minutes of
fame right i'm like i can take this and
run with it or i can forget about it
people are interested in what i have to
say for a limited amount of time
so i have the opportunity to take this
book that i'm going to read anyway
and why not invite other people to read
it with me so that was how the r for
data science online
learning community the concept started
but when hadley retweets you you have a
limited amount of time to get people
like still interested in what you're
saying right like i can't wait two weeks
and come back and be like hey i have
this cool idea like you have to
move so it's all about finding your
opportunities people
so i have to come up with this plan and
my idea is like well i don't want to
spend any money on this and i don't want
anybody else to have to spend any money
on this we shouldn't have to spend money
to learn how to do data science where
we're repurposing things we already know
how to do
so it's like it's going to be free it's
going to be open to whoever wants to be
a part of it and so the original idea
was let's create a slack group
and let's follow this curriculum map
that goes through maybe two chapters of
the textbook every week and we'll finish
in three to four months
and we'll all be data scientists at the
end we'll be pros we'll be total experts
it's going to be amazing
and one thing we did with this group
that i think is different from some
other online learning communities
is that we made it very clear that you
had to be nice to people
and you would be kicked out if you
weren't nice this was going to be the
kind of place where you could come
and we could say you could say i only
have two pains in our studio and i know
i'm supposed to have four and i don't
know what to do
and instead of someone being like loser
you're so new at this
people will be like hey you know what i
can help you with that and i'm going to
stick with you until we figure that out
and so that was the idea for the kind of
people you were going to encounter
and then last week we had this idea of
there being mentors and learners
so you self-identified am i here to
mentor other people in their learning
journey or am i here to learn
and maybe you were a learner for the
first three chapters and then you became
a mentor for other things so it was this
very fluid definition we weren't going
to say
oh we've done this survey and you are a
mentor and you are a learner like you
got to identify
you got to take responsibility for your
role in the community
so expectations versus reality
i feel like i go on about that like i've
got like three hours of material on this
i will keep it brief
essentially i was like no one's going to
want to do this with me this is an awful
idea but what like why not try i figured
at the end of two weeks i'd be begging
my friends to do this with me there'd be
12 of us
maybe 25 maybe 50 in this online
learning community
and i'm like that's fine that's fine
it's fine um
at the end of two weeks when the invites
went out we had over 600 members
uh which which for me meant that i'm not
there as a learner anymore i'm there as
a community manager
and that was that was a surprise that
was something i wasn't expecting
but as we we moved into things and i
started thinking about what worked and
what didn't work
um there was there was a lot but i would
say of the 600 people
within the first two weeks we lost half
of our members
and we lost our members for one of two
reasons
one slack was overwhelming right like
most of us probably use slack and are
like oh i'm so tired of this tool like
it's amazing but like stop sending me
stuff but you know how to navigate it
not everybody knows how to navigate
slack not everybody knows how to turn
their notifications off and when you log
in and all of a sudden there's 450
messages you're done
you are out right but we also had people
who couldn't
install or navigate are in our studio
and that's where we lost 50 of our
members was because we couldn't help
them get over those hurdles and we
didn't even think of those as
necessarily being the first hurdles
so again this this gap from your
computer for netflix to your computer
for data science is very very real
there was also a misalignment and
probably some miscommunication on my
part about what we were doing
so some of the biggest things was people
showed up and they were like what time
do classes start
i was like they don't we're just going
to read the book together and like
you're on your own and i'm not going to
tell you when to do things or how to do
things so that
that was a big thing we had people who
were like what book like what is the
book
um so that was a little bit lost in in
translation and then and then another
thing was that
um not everybody was tidy verse aligned
now listen if you don't if you're having
trouble installing r and r studio on
your computer i don't expect you to know
the difference between basar and the
tidy verse but if
if you're not there to help people learn
the tidy verse which is kind of a
central
organizing principle of the book it's
going to be some rough sledding
so there was a lot to work out and we
also i didn't provide any training for
mentors i was like yeah you know how to
be a mentor
forget the fact that we send teachers to
school to be certified in teaching i was
like you're fine just be nice it'll be
good it'll all work out
so at the end of round one i was
exhausted this was
like i just want to say people are like
data science is so hard
if you want a hard job go be a community
manager because that is exhausting
i like if you know a community manager
in your life give them a hug thank them
for what they do that is a
thankless career and it is incredibly
difficult
so there is this happened right and and
i was exhausted i didn't read the book
i hadn't finished the book i was
spending all of my time answering
twitter dms creating content
answering slack messages helping connect
people so i had really moved into a
community manager role and
it wasn't quite what i expected um i
will say that we did have one person who
copped to finishing the entire
curriculum um the guys at
hopkins tell me that is well within the
margin of error and that i should be
very very proud of that one person and i
am
i'm also proud of myself for doing
something before i was ready
and i'm really really proud of the
people who are like yeah this is a crazy
idea but i'm gonna do it
like everybody who came along on that
first adventure i am incredibly proud of
for taking a risk and trying something
new so then people are like hey when's
round two
so in round two i was like i can't do
this by myself something needs to change
and i said what do you all want to see
in this community
and people came back with all sorts of
ideas and when they said i really want
to see this i said that is a fantastic
idea
how can i support you in making that a
reality
and what that did is it resulted in
people being like oh no i don't want to
do the thing
and okay that's great then it's not
going to get done but it also resulted
in people saying
well i need you to help me to research
software or i need you to retweet
something or i need you to just kind of
like
help me talk in the group and recruit
people for this and those were things
that i could do
so in round two we had a lot of amazing
things happen
we had commitments to office hours where
people would give up an hour of their
week and just show up and answer
questions
we did github we did the chapters out of
the book
we had youtube tutorial videos that
community members made
and then three things that you're
probably most familiar with is we have a
website
we have a twitter account and we have
tidy tuesday these are not things that i
built
i made sure everybody got in slack and
that everybody was happy and well
behaved and nice to each other these are
things that community members have built
and the community members to this day
maintained
if you want to get involved in this
online learning community
you can go to that website and sign up
and i
strongly encourage you to do so so when
we're getting through round two i'm
realizing that the group
isn't what i set out to do right we're
not
going through a text together and
necessarily learning at
a specific pace but it's also an amazing
community and people are doing amazing
things
they're just not quite the things that i
want to do
so i am very excited to say that the
group was handed off to a new set of
leaders who are enthusiastic and
incredibly talented at what they do in
keeping this group running
and they they're just they're incred i
think they were saying that there were
over 2 500 members
today right so the community continues
to grow it continues to be active it
continues to be a place where you can go
and give and get help in r
so in my time away from the group i
started to think about
a lot of things and i thought a lot
about my life and how data science has
changed my life
right just doing this community just
learning data science just being a data
science
scientist has has changed my life it's
changed the people that i have access to
it has given me opportunities that i
would never before have had in my life
and it has completely changed my
socioeconomic status
instead of living in a financial crisis
every single day of my life
i'm like two emergencies away from a
financial crisis
right and that's a big deal when you
grow up in poverty and you can't put
food on the table like to have that
security so i was like
if data science has done this for me
then it can do it for other people and
it's my responsibility to help make it
easier for other people
move into data science and i think we
can all agree
that data is used data and data science
is used every single day
about by and for every single one of us
to make choices and decisions for us
data is integral to our lives and it
will be
for the foreseeable future so as i
started to look around data science as a
whole
and i was like data science affects each
and every one of us
so each and every one of us deserves a
seat at the table
so what i'm asking people to do there's
like a laundry list of a million things
i could ask you to do to start getting
more people into data science and making
it easier
to to bring people into data science and
removing some of the barriers
but i'm only going to ask you to do one
thing i'm going to ask you to be
vulnerable
i'm going to ask you to help me
demystify data science
share publicly on twitter on your blog
posts in person
the things that you don't know share the
things that you're learning
and share the mistakes that you've made
data science isn't special data science
isn't even necessarily a
difficult career i think the more
there's no there's no checklist for data
science where we say
oh great i have done every item on this
list and then hadley wickham descends
from the heavens and like knights you a
data scientist and everything like now
you are free to practice data science
go do data science and and share with
people because what data science is
is it's about constantly learning and
growing and taking risks i would argue
that that is one of the defining
characteristics
of being in data science right that
you're constantly learning
you're constantly making mistakes and
you're constantly learning from mistakes
and the more that we normalize that and
we say hey this is what us
the people who get paid to be data
scientists do
i think the more that we can start
bringing in diverse voices
and making data science as a community
more equitable and inclusive
with that i think i might be able to
take one question
i don't know i mean is my time keeper
okay
[Applause]
or you don't have any questions and
that's fine too you can always reach out
to me on twitter
hi thanks for your talk yeah thanks for
being brave and vulnerable and all those
things
um so when when you stepped away from
the community who was it that took over
and what was a part of that decision
to it yes so two of the people in this
room one
is a gentleman named dennis who is um i
can't remember
i think he's in kenya and then we have
thomas mock in the back he has
got tidy tuesday stickers i'm just
putting that out there
and then john harmon also over here on
the end so these are the gentlemen that
are currently running the community and
keeping it alive and making sure
everything is is going as planned
[Music]
you